-Yeah!
Hey, looking good, pal.
Thanks so much for doing this.
-Thank you for having me.
-Originally, the plan was that
you were going to appear
in studio tonight.
-Right.
-But that didn't work out
because there's now
a quarantine.
You're home in L.A. now, right?
Correct?
-I was on -- so, yesterday
I was in New York.
So I flew to New York to be
on your show
and right when we landed, we
got word that there was, like,
a new mandate or whatever,
new rules going on
where we couldn't do the show
anymore.
So I was in New York,
and my hotel was literally
across from your studio.
So I was looking at it
and we were getting the text,
like, we have to do the
interview on Zoom now.
So I was just staring
at your studio, I was like,
it's right there,
I can literally --
Like, I can do it
through the window.
And then, yeah,
and I didn't see it.
I went for a run though, and I
got to run right by the studio.
So that felt nice.
It kind of felt like
I was on the show.
-You sent a photo that you
took last night.
This is real. This --
You actually were there!
That's bizarre.
-Yeah.
-You actually were here.
-Look, I peed all over
the front of it because
I was so angry
at not being able to --
That's just me.
-It just made you have
to do it.
-Making sure you knew
I was there.
-Dude, I'm so bummed
because we had some fun bits
planned and all that stuff.
But when everything goes
back to normal,
you have an open invitation,
Please, to come back to
the studio anytime.
Okay?
-Okay, good.
-Hey, I got something
in the mail from you.
-Oh, no way!
-I did not open it.
And I was waiting to open it
while you're on the show.
Now, you're not a prankster.
So nothing's going to
blow up, right?
-No, nothing's going to blow up
but I can't believe you got --
I always assume that if you send
something to a big celebrity
like this, it would get --
like it goes through like
ten different people,
and they're like,
um, not this, not this.
But it got to you.
-I get everything.
So this is something from you.
In this cool -- I like the box.
-Thank you so much.
-Like a diamond --
I get it. "D."
-Open it up.
David Dobrik, diamond.
"DDD."
Is it a diamond ring?
-No, it's not a diamond ring.
It's perfume.
-I'm already bummed.
-It will get you closer
to a diamond ring.
-[ Gasps ]
-Look at that.
You got to open --
Jimmy, open that card.
That card I got you right there.
The one that's sitting
right on top.
-Okay.
-Open it up.
-David Dobrik's debut fragrance
collection, available now.
-Hey, Jimmy, it's
David Dobrik.
I know this isn't a fair
exchange,
but I'm sending you
my perfume in hopes
of maybe you giving me your job.
I know it's not
the fairest of exchanges,
but it would mean the world.
[ Laughter ]
All right, I see you soon.
Bye.
-This is -- only you
would do --
[ Laughter ]
-That's the first bribe of many.
-That's fantastic.
Wait, so -- one for me --
-The boxes of cash are
on their way.
-Grapefruit, sandalwood,
amber, and cashmere.
Ooh, sounds fancy.
Which one do I do?
The pink or the black one?
I'm assuming --
-I think you'd like the black
one more.
Honestly.
I'm being serious.
I really think
you would enjoy it.
-David's perfume.
-[ Laughs ]
-Now...
why not call it cologne?
-Perfume is just
a lot better of a word.
-[ Laughs ] It kind of is.
Yeah, you're right.
All right, here we go.
All right, ready?
Oh.
I love it.
I'm in. I love it.
-Even if it would have smelled
like dog poop,
you would have been like...
-No.
-..."This is delicious."
-No, it's fresh.
It's amber and cashmere.
It's good. It's clean.
I love it.
Dude, I'm so -- hey, whoa!
-Magnetic cap. Oh, my God.
That's exactly the reaction
I wanted from people!
-Magnetic cap! Come on!
[ Laughter ]
Dude, I love it, man.
Congrats.
That's so rad.
-Ah, thank you so much.
-Thank you for sending me this.
I appreciate it, buddy.
-Thank you for opening it
on television.
-You know, you were back
on our show in June
when I was still
doing the show from home,
and I appreciate you doing that
because I told you back then
and I'm telling it now,
but I felt like --
I felt like you.
-Yeah?
-Like the old man version
of David Dobrik.
That was, it was almost like
you looking at your future.
And I was -- I was vlogging
for four months.
-You've definitely
stepped it up,
and your vlogging was actually
very killer.
It was mainly your
graphic design team,
which was your two daughters.
That's what made it the best.
That's what really sent you
over the edge.
-Thank you.
-You have been vlogging
more than I have.
-Yeah.
-I haven't posted in 7 months.
-You told me that.
We talked about this.
And then you posted something
the other day with Borat.
-Yeah.
-That was your first one back
and it was crusher.
Gosh, he is so funny.
How did that come --
-He is the funniest man I have
ever gotten to interact with.
He came -- It was --
Well, first off, I DM'd him
like four weeks ago,
and then I got a DM back
like two days prior
to shooting with him.
And he was like,
"Yes, I'd love to come by."
And his team told me,
they're like,
"Borat wants to meet you
as Borat."
Like, I wasn't meeting
anybody else.
I was meeting Borat for the
first time on camera.
So it was a really cool thing
that I got to meet him
in person,
like live right there.
And he pulled right in, and he
went right into his character
and just stayed in character
for the entire time
we were hanging out.
It was hilarious.
-Interesting.
-Such a funny dude.
-Yeah, he is a genius.
-Such a funny guy.
-I love that guy.
I loved your videos.
And, you know,
we did a bit together.
I was just thinking like,
when did it all happen?
You just moved to L.A.
from high school?
And you --
Did you have any plan?
-I moved to L.A.
when I was about 18.
And my parents gave me
an ultimatum.
They were like, "You either go
to college or you move out."
And I remember a week later,
I, like,
asked three of my friends
that weren't doing anything.
I really didn't even talk
to them much.
But I knew they weren't
doing anything
and that they weren't
going to college
and they could help me
split the rent in L.A.
so I found a two-bedroom
for the four of us to live in,
and I told my parents,
I'm like, "I'm moving to L.A."
And I remember my dad --
it was my --
Like, they both laughed.
Like, it was like the cliché.
Like, your parents are like,
"Ah-ha-ha."
My dad's like,
"Where you are going to move,
Hollywood Boulevard?"
And I went, "Yeah, literally.
The place I'm living at is
on Hollywood and Highland."
I was like, "That's exactly
where I'm going."
-"I'm actually going
to Hollywood Boulevard."
-Yeah, and I remember --
That was like
a big thing for them.
They did not under--
they still don't understand.
They're still confused
and they're still so worried
about me, they're like,
"You need to go back
to college."
But these help --
these interviews help,
because then they go, "Oh, okay.
Jimmy Fallon, okay, very nice."
-"You're doing something.
All right, good, yeah.
All right, good, yeah."
Well, you've made a pretty good
mark so far, buddy.
-Thanks.
-You are always using
your platform
to spread positivity.
It's always fun.
You did something incredible
recently.
You partnered with HeadCount
and you single handedly
helped get 120,000 people
registered to vote.
What inspired to you to do this?
How did you pull this off?
It's amazing.
-Yeah, that was crazy.
I don't know.
Well, I'm a DACA kid, myself,
so I can't vote.
So I thought...
-Are you really?
I didn't know this.
-Yeah, yeah.
I need all the help I can get
from people going out
and voting on my behalf.
So I thought maybe I can use
that to my advantage
and be like, hey guys,
please, for the love of God,
go out there and help me stay
in this country by voting.
And yeah, and it worked out.
I don't know if it's because
they wanted to help me out
or because they
wanted a free car
because I was giving away Teslas
as an incentive.
But regardless, I'm really glad
with the turnout.
-The founder of HeadCount
called your --
called what you did
"absolutely unprecedented."
And they have --
HeadCount has registered
1 million voters
in its lifetime,
and you are responsible
for over 10% of that.
-Yeah, that's --
-Wow.
-Yeah, that's really cool.
-Congrats, buddy.
You should you be very proud
of that.
That's really cool.
-Thank you so much, yeah.
-David, stay safe.
Thank you for flying out here.
Thank you for flying back.
Thank you for doing
all the right things.
-Yeah, it was the best.
-You know we love you, man.
And stay safe, pal, okay?
-Thank you so much.
It was good seeing you.
I'll see you in a couple months.
-David Dobrik, everybody.
Check out his YouTube channel
and make a plan to vote.